joining us here on the phone as man
who's been covering sports for the
Oklahoman as a sports columnist since
1991 and unfortunately is uh
on everybody's lips because of the fact
that Russell Westbrook won't talk to him
he's Barry Trammell of the Oklahoman
kinda have to call him to show how are
you Barry I'm doing fine
so first up with you is is essentially
what what can you explain to those who
are watching the postgame press
conferences with with Russell Westbrook
and what is actually happening with him
and you Barry Oh Russ has not been too
partial to me for about four years I
don't really know what started I don't
know about four years ago he said he
didn't like me and so on off and on over
those four years
we sort of had valleys
about three months ago he didn't like
particular question and since then he
hasn't answered any of my questions and
it's sort of a thing in Oklahoma but I
didn't know is it is any big deal and
then the playoffs come and the spotlight
hits and people start watching the press
conferences and now the whole nation
seems excited about it so that's really
what's going on but it's nothing
particularly new well I mean uh is he an
angry person I mean what what what what
is what what is he so upset about if you
if you don't know what it is have you
haven't you spoken to him about it very
no no no no there's not there's not any
kind of relationship there and it's not
just me it's nothing personal I don't
take this personal because it's not
personal Russell doesn't really like
anyone in the media don't have a
relationship with much of anybody in the
media he just sort of fingered me out
maybe because I'm been around the
longest bit there's no there's no
discussions I mean I've had he's been in
town eleven years and of course I've
been around forever and we've had
to conversations outside of the
interview setup one of those
conversations was three seconds four
seconds in which he shook my hand at
Abbey today said hey how you doin I said
great and great to see you that was that
and then a couple three years ago I
found out through thunder channels that
he was upset with a particular question
and they said they this person said you
know what you might have came across
ronk on that interview on that question
to which I said well maybe I don't know
but I'll be glad to apologize so I
followed him out of locker room one
night said hey Russell I heard you got
offended at that question hey that was
not my intent I apologized he shook my
hand and said hey that's no problem
thanks that's literally the only
conversations we've had other than me
asking him a question about a basketball
so there's no relationship here there's
no process by which we could sit down or
even stand up talk it out that does not
occur in Oklahoma City sort of the
culture that they built it's bad it's a
bad move on the franchise's part but
it's the road they decided to go down
and the problem with it is you can reach
a point like where we're at now well and
then my query trembled The Oklahoman
here on the Rich Eisen show you know
people might be listening to us right
now saying well poor member of the media
not getting his answer is questions
answered etc etc so to those folks I
what what do you think this does for the
franchise there and and how has it
affected do you think the team the
attitude that we don't have to answer to
to anybody or people that might
represent the fan base I mean how does
this manifest itself of this behavior do
you think very well on the court I don't
know that I don't know that it's got any
kind of serious ramifications other than
it's a symptom that you know the Thunder
is sort of turned over total control to
Russell Westbrook
when Kevin Durant last three years ago
the state was death the state
the city was devastated everybody was at
a state of mourning and about a month
later Russell says hey you know I'm I'm
still with you and he signed a one-year
contract extension a year after that he
signed the five-year contract extension
and basically just endeared himself to
the entire state for all time but the
Thunder has always been really
accommodating to Russell handing him
quite a bit of control of the
proceedings with the Thunder and since
then since he declared you know with
those contract extensions it's
completely out of control this is
special Westbrook franchise and that's
probably not a good thing for any for
any sport any franchise to to cede that
kind of control
I don't I you probably argue that it's
not good for the Cavaliers or the Lakers
or whoever had you LeBron James and he's
LeBron James delivering ice cream chips
so it's you know it's a bad look and the
truth is Russell is still beloved but
people have their limits and I'm I'm not
a neutral observer I'm in the middle of
this so I'm Paulo my feedback three
years ago if I was at war with Russell
Westbrook my name would be mud and
people would be very angry with me
there's not much anger coming my way
people are very supportive people inside
the organization people outside the
organization fans people at the arena
say hey I don't know why Russell's
acting this way hang in there so I think
he damaged himself and I know he's
damaged the franchise and it's just very
unfortunate because and I don't want
this to happen not a hopeful no I don't
want the Thunder to suffer but I also
I'm not going to seek control you know
Russell tries to control everything he
doesn't get my little corner when I say
my the media all the media in general he
doesn't get our little corner of the
world he can't run us so that's real
why I keep asking him questions and so
if they go out tonight are you in
Portland right now and the first
question you'll ask is of Russell
Westbrook tonight that's my plan alone
in Portland and I will ask him a
question night win or lose okay I will
and you know Sunday night got me they
caught my attention berry was was Friday
night because I you know again I'm not
watching Paul George as closely as you
are but I'm watching him next question
the question that was asked of him about
dunking on the Blazers with no time left
and then you asking questions of Russell
before that and him essentially asking
Westbrook for permission essentially to
answer on his behalf that kind of caught
me off guard that is Paul George now
being taken down this path by his
teammate and and will that be somehow a
problem for the franchise well it's a
great question and you're exactly right
Friday night I think was the tipping
point because that was an awful look
Paul George was a pretty good reputation
around the league pretty accommodating
affable guy pretty solid and he seemed
to jump on the westbrook train that
night and it did not go across good with
anybody that I know fans
yeah and leaked members when Steve Kerr
comes out and says hey this isn't good
this is a problem I I think it's reached
a point where something had to give and
something did give Russell on Sunday did
not say that's question now he didn't
answer my question
but he lived off of high center and he
when people asked me about it I said I
just appreciated his tone
he wasn't certainly wasn't the ball he
just sort of talked in a normal voice
when he didn't answer my questions and
to me that's progress
so you know both mobile phones will it
come alright well last question for you
on this front before we move to
to kind Lemuria and the draft berry
travel of The Oklahoman here on the Rich
Eisen show bill simmons is one of many
observers out there thinking that the
the Thunder might be better off parting
ways with Russell Westbrook and sending
him elsewhere in rebuilding from scratch
what do you think that would be an
interesting concept I just can't imagine
him doing it because of what your song
has meant to the franchise in the wake
of Kevin Durant believing their aunt
left on July 4th nineteen imeem 2016 and
I can't express to you the mood of that
day when the news came about 10:45 in
the morning and frankly do you know I
fall formal been the same sense every
tie for that supposed to be everybody's
favorite day salvation oh go to the
beach have a have a parade have a party
oklahomans sort of light a candle so
this was the day the music died and for
Russell Westbrook to sort of take up the
flag and say you know what we're going
to keep marching on was such an amazing
decision on by Westbrook
I think would be very tough for this
franchise to to make that decision Bill
Simmons is right Russell's going to be
31 next year his game is in decline
still a wonderful player and his game is
in decline his contract is going through
the roof it's it's going to be an
albatross very soon if it's not already
so business-wise yes that's the best
thing to do motional ii i just can't see
the thunder pulling that trigger
Barry Trammell of the Oklahoman here on
the Rich Eisen show ok the potential
first overall pick in this year's draft
played his collegiate football last year
20 miles down the road from you in
Norman Oklahoma all the look you can
hear all sorts of red flags about
anybody the red flags about Kyler Murray
this year from the fact that he was
unprepared on the grease board as at the
combine to talk about X's and O's as
Charlie casually
said he came on calamari came on my show
at the the Super Bowl before strolling
down the the hallway to Dan Patrick and
was it was just bizarre how he was not
prepared to answer questions about his
playing future when he knew those
questions were coming how much of that
stuff rings true based on what you know
about calamari berry the second part
rings true now the the the whiteboard
stuff I don't have any idea he certainly
none of that at Oklahoma he was fabulous
as a quarterback he punched all the
buttons just a wonderful player at every
regard I don't know what goes on behind
closed doors and football preparation I
got no clue on that I respect charlie
casually I respect Lincoln right I don't
know who's right
the unpreparedness was striking though
the truth is I think Kyle Murray got
caught it's sort of a vortex I don't
think he's a confident guy he had high
goals and high aspirations but not even
he or his father I think we're prepared
for him to be the night to pick overall
in the Baseball Draft I don't think they
had any idea that he could be the number
one pick in the NFL Draft I think both
of these things just sort of landed on
top of their head and they weren't ready
for it they signed on boss I mean sorry
Scott Morris Scott Boras is one of them
in all most powerful people in baseball
and you know clearly expected and wanted
Tyler to sign with the A's and he did
and to me it became pretty clear that
Kyra wanted to play football but he had
this baseball contract pulling him and I
think they would just I think they were
just sort of blindsided by the enormity
of the situation so they weren't
prepared for it and frankly nobody
really probably could expect him to I
think Cairo Murray's a solid guy he's uh
he's not brash he's not he
any more loose than anything you know
everybody used to bake or make you you
know I sit around and wonder what's
going on and Baker Mayfield mind he'll
just tell you it's Joe Murray Murray is
a quiet
he's introspective you don't real have a
good read on him so he's a little bit of
him a little bit of an enigma but I
would say for the NFL purposes the
biggest question about Cara Maria's
everybody's question is is he big enough
I think he's good enough but is he big
enough reason to think he is because
Russell Wilson Baker Mayfield Drew Brees
but we're gonna have to see I think
football acumen I think he's going to be
fine physically we'll see I got Marquis
Grant Brown coming to studio in the next
hour he and uh obviously mari are two
standouts from Oklahoma what which kid
are you looking forward to seeing at the
next level that you've watched play
either at Oklahoma Oklahoma State over
the last couple of years very well
Marquis Brown is fun
Marquis Brown is as fast as anybody I've
seen play football Oklahoma or Oklahoma
State helia sort of a San Tyree kill and
I mean he's a home run hitter and the
thing I like about Marcus Brown is you
know with with with Mayfield and then
Murray the system 60 yard bombs were
sort of a staple but Lincoln Riley
figured out ways sort of the way the
Chiefs abused Tyree kill throwing the
fourth yard pass and maybe you can turn
it into 40 you can turn that corner so
that speed is is amazing on Archie
sprout he's awfully fun right you can't
take your eyes off of a quarterback
every snap cover Murray's going to give
you something to to discern wherever he
ends up so I think the kind of Murray
experiment with the NFL is going to be
fascinating if he succeeds then the
revolution is not just over I mean not
just begun I think it's over I think
it's one that small
quarterbacks are the wave of the future
or at least a part of this little berry
I appreciate the two cents on that look
nobody in the media wants to be part of
the spotlight or part of the story and I
appreciate you calling to share all of
that before tonight so potentially
closeout game of the Thunder season
appreciate it okay you bet that's Barry
Trammell at Barry Trammell on Twitter
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app